[Music]
so for a long time
oil has played a special role in
American foreign policy and military
strategy oil is a uniquely important
commodity in global affairs it's an
input to everything in our modern way of
life it's very important for protecting
our prosperity and at a certain level
oil is essential for high quality
military power to fight you need access
to oil and in the Cold War the United
States was concerned that the Soviet
Union could interrupt American access to
Persian Gulf oil which we needed in
order to defend Europe defend our own
interests against the Soviet Union and
so we took it on as a military mission
to protect key sources of oil supplies
around the world especially in the
Persian Gulf from outside interference
so from the Soviet Union being able to
threaten them now of course for a long
time the Soviet Union hasn't existed
that particular scenario hasn't posed a
challenge for the United States but the
United States has feared oil is
continued to play a role in American
foreign and military policy because the
United States has feared that political
disruptions in the Middle East internal
instability the threat of extremist
fundamentalist Muslim control in the
Middle East if that came about could
pose a threat to American oil supplies
that especially would hurt our
prosperity right that they could they
could make us poor and so we've used
military force to try to reduce
instability in parts of the world
especially the Persian Gulf where we're
afraid that instability would threaten
global oil markets that policy has both
been largely unnecessary and largely
ineffective so it has happened that
there was a moment where it seemed to
work very well when we sent troops in
1990 to defend Saudi Arabia from Saddam
Hussein who had just conquered Kuwait
and then we liberated Kuwait in the Gulf
War but did not continue to attack Iraq
and the result of this was to maintain
access to Persian Gulf oil to maintain
the independence of a number of Persian
Gulf oil producers and that made sense
in a bunch of ways but then since that
time we've actually become a primary
threat to stability in the Middle East
rather than a primary guarantor of
stability in the Middle East and that
when we invaded Iraq we set in motion a
lot of events created a much more
salient internal stability challenge for
many countries in the in the Persian
Gulf by by hardening and militarizing
domestic conflicts in a lot of these
countries between Sunnis and Shiites
between different brands of within Sunni
Islam or within shade we've created
internal instability that we can't
address very well from outside right the
United States lacks
the detailed information to understand
and manipulate the politics of these
countries instead we get manipulated by
local actors that in a sense makes the
instability worse so if you think of it
this way in the United States we spend a
lot of time thinking about in studying
American politics and elections but we
don't understand American politics very
well even with all of the background
cultural knowledge we have an
understanding of our own politics
nobody expected President Trump to rise
as a phenomenon and become president we
don't understand our own politics how
can we expect to understand and
manipulate the politics of faraway
countries in the Persian Gulf where we
don't know the local personage as well
we don't know the situation on the
ground we don't know what contributes to
people's political activism although we
can actually be fairly sure of one thing
that contributes which is they don't
like the feeling that they're being
pushed around by outside influences like
the United States showing up and telling
them what to do and so we can create
hostility to the United States by saying
oh we're showing up to defend the
stability of Middle East oil supplies
but we can't actually defend Middle East
oil supplies from local instability in
the Middle East
very well and so we've actually created
a lot of the problems in the oil market
however all of that said the global oil
market protects us so we don't actually
have to worry as much about that kind of
instability in any particular oil
supplier so what happens in the oil
market is when there's a disruption in
one country of the world that reduces
their oil supplies their ability to
supply the global market to supply
consumers like us in the United States
when there's that kind of a disruption
other suppliers compensate so suppliers
that aren't comp that aren't disrupted
see an opportunity to make more money
for themselves by increasing their oil
output to compensate for the fact that
one of their competitors has reduced
their oil output so for example when
Libya exploded into civil war and then
US and European intervention wrecked -
the state institutions of that country
and made the Civil War last not just a
few months in 2011 but persist for the
last seven years such that Libyan oil
output is way down millions of barrels a
day down compared to what it was before
2011 didn't lead to a huge disruption of
the oil market didn't lead to a big
price surge for consumers like the
United States because other producers of
oil like Saudi Arabia like the United
Arab Emirates like Mexico you know all
around the world increased their output
to compensate for the fact that Libya
was producing less and so the natural
market reaction without the US military
doing anything enables consumers to
continue consuming in the face of
political military disruptions of the
oil market in one country around the
world so we don't need to try to use the
American military to protect oil markets
because the market compensates for
disruptions and in fact our track record
of using the US military to protect oil
markets is lousy it often makes the
problems worse not
and so there's a clear policy adjustment
the United States could make to stop
using the military for this purpose and
that would make Americans safer and
continue to give us a reliable oil
supply
[Music]